in the last video i hopefully showed you
that if i
borrowed p dollars
if i borrowed p dollars and i borrowed
for a year and you were to charge me an
interest rate of r
right or you could say 10 r percent
then at the end and we were to compound
continuously so you know we compound
every zillionth of a second but we
compounded you know a tr trillion times
however many of those uh intervals are
on a year that at the end of the year
i would owe you p
times e to the r
dollars
fair enough now what happens if i borrow
it for two years
well after one year we already said that
that i would owe you p times e to the r
dollars right
and then after two years what happens
well this becomes the new principle you
can kind of view it as like i borrowed
this much then i owed this much after a
year and so this is the new principle so
i can re-borrow this right so if i
re-borrow this this becomes the new p
so that becomes the new p
so i could write p
e to the r
and it's going to and that new principle
is going to compound for another year
so e to the r
so that equals p
e to the 2r and similarly
this is now my new principle if i were
to borrow it for another year
if i were to borrow it for another year
it becomes p
e to the 3r so in general if i borrow p
dollars that's my initial principle i
borrow it at a at a rate of r
and i borrow it for t years the amount
that i owe after t years is p e
to the r t
and and once you know this you are ready
to become a your your local uh banker
and and lend people money continuously
and let me just do a couple of examples
because i think it might be a little
confusing in the abstract but with some
numbers it might all clear up
okay so let's say i borrow
one thousand dollars
i borrow one thousand dollars let's say
that the interest rate
is
i don't know 25 that's the annual
interest rate
right
rate is equal to 25 which is the same
thing as 0.25
and let's say i were to borrow it for
three years so t is equal to
three
years and
we're going to continuously compound
this interest
so
our formula says that the amount that
i'll owe at the end of this is how much
i borrowed
one thousand dollars
times e
to my interest rate power
0.25 times the number of years
times t
and so let's uh oh sorry that's 3
right so that equals 1000
e to the
0.75 power
and let me calculate what that is in
excel and just so you know i don't if
you're familiar with excel in excel the
e to the power so i wrote there it's a
thousand
times
e to a power in excel is x
so that's e to some power and in this
case it's 0.75
and so i get
my answer oh i don't know i think it
fell off the bottom of the screen there
it is right here that's my answer let me
zoom in a little bit because i think you
might have trouble reading it because it
kind of shrinks it when i go to youtube
two thousand one hundred and seventeen
dollars
it equals
two thousand one hundred and seventeen
dollars and that's what you would owe me
at the end of three years and that this
is actually the power of compounding
interest a lot of people you know when
you hear 10 interest rate or even a 25
interest rate
no one really makes a a big deal about
it but when you compound it and
especially when you compound it
continuously it can very quickly uh turn
into into very very large numbers
let's let's do another example and this
might be another uh kind of a more
complicated example but or something
that you might actually see in a in a
textbook let's say that
you know i borrow
fifty dollars
i borrow fifty dollars and after and
let's say it's continuously compounded
at some rate
r
unless it's consent continuously
compounded for 10 years
and at the end of 10 years and at the
end of 10 years i owe
what was the rate at which it was
compounded
so once again we can use the same
formula we could say well if my original
principal is fifty dollars
so
it's going to be fifty dollars times e
to the rate we don't know the rate
but we know the t that t is equal to 10
years so it's 10
r
that equals my final payment or how much
i oh once all of the interest had and
the principal has compounded
is equal to 500
so we can divide both sides by 50 you
get e to the 10 r
is equal to
10.
and then how do we solve that well we
could take the log base e of both sides
hopefully you might want to review the
logarithm but you know log
base e e is just a number if you ever
get confused is equal to
log
base e of 10 and log base e on your
calculator
is often written the natural log and
they call it the natural log because it
will show i'll show you e in a hundred
different applications not a hundred but
in many different applications it shows
up all over nature and i think that's
why it's called the natural log
but anyway let me see if i can figure
out what excel's natural log function is
so i need to figure out the natural log
log base e
of 10
equals ln
10.
oh there we go 2 point
there it is right there 2.3
so i get
so first of all if i say you know log
base e of e to the 10 r that's like
saying e to what power is equal to e to
the 10r
so this
is the same thing
as just 10r
right why is that because remember
logarithm is an exponent so this is
saying e to the 10 r is equal to e to
the 10 r review my logarithm videos if
that's a little confusing i know it's a
little confusing at first and then we
just figured out that log base e so e to
the what power is 10 is 2 point what was
the number two point
three
oh
and now and oh this isn't 10 to the r
this is 10r right and so we want to
figure out what r as we divide both
sides by 10 we get r is equal to 0.2
0.23
or 23 percent
so essentially if if i continuously
compound at an annual rate of 23
after 10 years i'll essentially
essentially owe 10 times the money so
that's something good to keep in mind
anyway i'll leave you there and and i
really encourage you to go back a couple
of videos re-watch them play with the
numbers prove to yourself that that
limit exists take that limit that we
showed in the beginning the limit as n
approaches infinity
of 1 over 1 plus
n to the n and all you have to do to
prove this is just put in larger and
larger numbers for n and of course
whatever number you put it here you have
to put over here you can't put a million
here in the trillion there you have to
put a trillion and a trillion or a
million in a million and you'll see that
it converges to e and re-watch the
videos and make sure you get kind of an
intuitive understanding of everything we
did and then this formula which most
people frankly just memorize is p e to
the rt will make a lot of sense to you
and and you will you will
you'll have a permanent neuron for the
rest of your life anyway i'll see you in
the next video